[Music]
and he has to give it up there McClung
beats the buzzer
[Applause]
they're gonna take a look but it looked
good
and he definitely got that off in time
Lakers fights 29.
[Music]
clung
oh he got clothesline still finished
[Applause]
it's practice and looks extremely good
went up and down did a lot of five and
five and by the time the season rolls
around it'll be about 18 months so
good it got way above athlete I think I
like that shot
hit him with the okey-doke
fast break points they got separation
every time with the defense and the
pressure they applied
the clown gets another one
through his legs tight Rider a little
pump faking he knocked that one down
love his size is shooting 66205
excellent pick for the Golden State
Warriors
McClung has the last six for the warrior
did God
[Music]
McClung
the nice pass inside and he had 11
points in the fourth quarter he was due
here today McClung up and under
[Music]
Wiseman right here
McClung spinning slicing Dyson and the
crowd is loving the crowd favorite Matt
McClung we'll watch Matt McClung around
the back a little Pearl through the legs
then the Europe and off the glass give
them everything
four seconds on the shot clock they've
gotta go McClung
Up and Under beating the clock and the
crowd is in a frenzy I just played Chris
mile drive it hard goes up under
switches hand with the left
plump
those years of mediocrity if you will no
Lakota Wiseman
[Applause]
comes down he looks off the roller and
throws it to White